citizens of the reject nation we got
ourselves an official trailer trailer
number two for pinocchio a disney plus
remake directed by robert the zamekas
reuniting with thomas the hanks covering
a lot of tom hanks randomly on this
channel lately horse gump green mile
kids go watch the green mile reaction
totally kid appropriate don't i'm just
messing with you tom hanks doesn't at
one point shout at pinocchio you are a
toy missed opportunity missed
opportunity disney anywho guys leave a
like uh i am planning on covering
pinocchio the this movie over here on
the channel gonna do a reaction to it i
did like the disney animated movie
growing up as a kid been many years
since i've actually seen it i don't know
if i should revisit it prior to because
i don't want to just do a shot by shot
comparison even though i'm sure it's
going to be kind of shot by shot remix
we'll see who knows anywho let's check
out the trailer
[Music]
and gentlemen
i present to you
the eighth wonder of the world
[Music]
the one and only
chimney crickets
[Applause]
hello pups
that looks great
i know it was real boy
turn around let me get a look at you
i will be right here when you get back
pinocchio is running around loose
without a conscience can you imagine the
trouble he's going to get into wouldn't
want that on my conscience everybody
who's anybody wants to be a somebody
love interest love interest would you
want to be real when you can be
famous
honest john baby
[Music]
pinocchio should have been home by now
did you have the cat
[Music]
you won't be a puppet anymore you know
this looks for sure
[Laughter]
oh my goodness
not non-selfish
[Music]
you will always be my real boy
that looks so
beautiful a lie can really change a
person pinocks oh what's happening
jiminy looks like some sort of fairy
magic
kind of on the nose if you ask me
[Laughter]
that that's like a little gross and
borderline suggestive and live action
just saying just saying i think a lot of
us are thinking and maybe just not
saying it but yeah come on come on come
on someone had to point it out yeah that
was a beautiful trailer i'm surprisingly
more swept up than that than i was
expecting yeah like many people i have a
very kind of up and down relationship
when it comes to the disney live-action
remakes but looking at this trailer this
is one that i would love to have seen in
the theaters i mean it's great to be
able to do reactions here at home not
gonna lie but at the same time when i
see something like this that looks
absolutely stunning and just beautiful
to behold like it really does capture
that wonder and then even the the
perilous parts like i remember pinocchio
i'm sure like many of you guys too kind
of scared the crap out of me when i was
a kid a lot of those moments uh you know
like when they were going through the
adventures and the rides and such that
that felt like oh this could actually be
dark and scary and it's semekis who's
not afraid to do that with the kids
movies i remember watching the the jim
carrey scrooge movie in the theaters and
being surprisingly a little scared you
know i almost thought that one time when
i was much younger and having that fear
evoked within me and i really do think
that he will actually honor that with
this film beyond that you know a lot of
these moments do look just absolutely
stunning and i like the the choice to
actually make the characters like
pinocchio included look animated what i
mean by that is because it seems to be
kind of a toss-up nowadays you know some
people really like that lion king remake
and others thought it broached too much
uncanny valley and trying to go for the
super realistic touch actually took away
from the movie i was more in that camp i
would say that i found it more
distracting and it actually lost some of
the emotion because of that because you
lose a lot of expression and such and i
feel like if they just tried going for
realistic pinocchio for this it might
have just been distracting and and maybe
looked a little bit odd and weird so the
fact that they just leaned into making
it look like the cartoon like that all
the round with honest john with jiminy
cricket the monstrose the whale right
try to recall names right now so i think
the fact that they leaned into uh the
cartoon elements makes it feel less
creepy because it could this could have
felt really creepy if not done right
especially with all the kinds of animal
characters that you do have brought to
life especially with this puppet you
know like there's been remember that
jonathan just remember right number the
jonathan taylor thomas pinocchio movie
it's been ages since i've seen that i
only saw that one time too
i don't remember if it was good was it
liked but yeah and then you also have
like tom hanks here who i think is you
know he's great casting for gepetto i've
been enjoying this latest stretch of tom
hanks a guy who's in wigs and makeup now
you know i just saw him in elvis now
seeing him in gepetto it seems like this
guy's you know experimenting a little
bit more in
his later years and just really trying
out uh different kinds of things as
opposed to just i'm going to show up as
tom hanks not that he usually does he's
always been a great character actor but
i like seeing him uh you know have a
little bit more fun in terms of the
makeup and the costumes and all that and
you know obviously him reuniting with
robert zemeckis is always a joy because
they've done so many movies together so
i'm excited for that element i haven't
seen the trailer for that guillermo del
toro one yet what are you guys more
excited for the guillermo del toro
version or this robert zemeckis one i
mean this one definitely plays more
without having seen the del toro trailer
the the impression that i would have is
that this is the faithful to the disney
adaptation and guillermo del toro's
really going to be doing his own thing i
am weirdly excited at the prospect of
having two different pinocchios coming
out at similar times just because you
can get two completely different flavors
because at the end of the day you know
disney did not invent pinocchio it's
based on source material so i'm looking
forward to both i mean the both
filmmakers i think uh have such great
legacies and i'm excited to see what
both can do and yeah i heard the
controversy when the teaser trailer came
out with uh cynthia revo as the fairy i
don't give a [ __ ]
like really i know some people that
really upsets them for some reason it's
a fictional fantasy character like it's
not a big deal the movie is about
pinocchio that's just a supporting
character doesn't even take up most of
the run time of the film maybe not even
half of the runtime of the film who
cares and cynthia's a great actress
watch some of her work she's a
phenomenal actress but yeah guys i
actually love this trailer i was really
swept up in the wonder thought it was
quite a quite a magical one i'm really
looking forward to watching it that was
a really surprisingly touching
experience leave your thoughts down
below you can subscribe click that bell
leave a like last but not least
andrew hayes oh my goodness what a rare
opportunity the one person in our
patreon that could possibly be uh a
former puppet that came to life looking
like a boy
andrew hayes it is your birthday today
buddy just happened to catch that so
happy birthday to you dude thank you so
much for being part of our patreon for
such a long time i hope you're having a
magical wonderful day hope you get a
party on the weekend with all your bros
because i know you got a lot of them
bros go out there have some fun don't
get into too many illegal things you
savage you but you know just be safe and
uh enjoy it live it up before you get
turned back into a wooden puppet my
friend love you buddy
[Music]
you